Back at the vegetable bed again, looking
at these early blighted tomatoes. So,
early blight is one of the most common
fungal diseases of tomatoes. This fungal
disease loves wet and warm conditions
and this is usually spread through
overcrowdedness and bad airflow and so
that comes with overcrowdedness. So,
that's the easiest fix without using any
type of substance. Oh, lost one. Blight
can also affect the stems and the leaves
as well. And usually this type of fungal
disease starts at the bottom of the
plant and works its way up. So if it
starts down here, leaves start falling
off and then you see some fruit like
this, you definitely have some light.
The stem damage is usually characterized
by brown dry spots. Sometimes sun come
in kind of like this one, but definitely
brown and dry. The first thing you
should do when you see blight on your
tomatoes is get rid of the affected
fruit. Get rid of
that. The next easiest fix is to use
something that we use at the garden
center and offer at the garden center.
It's copper fungicide. So, you can get
this. You can spray it right on the
plants and the tomatoes and it'll help
you mitigate your fungal infections and
spreads. And then you want to make sure
everything is getting good separation
and good
airflow. That's how you beat it.